how are you both doing well how are you
uh I'm gonna say I'm doing excellent uh
we're talking about a good movie that
made me laugh a lot and uncomfortably
laugh a lot uh so I'm gonna say thank
you
um I am curious I think my most
important question is up first
um how much does it actually cost to be
in a movie with Eddie Murphy like what
did you pay Netflix to say I can let me
work with Eddie I promised them my first
born child
that was it yeah that's all got it I
promised them three kids so
we'll see how that plans out we're just
we're operating being serious like I I
love Eddie and I know you both love
Eddie uh and I also love Jonah and uh
I'm just curious what is it like
actually like getting to work with them
in a movie like this because Eddie is
the goat sorry for my language
the apology is unnecessary he's the
goat
um it's nerve-wracking it's for me
specifically because I
everybody on that set is so experienced
and I am the youngest in the least
experience so I was sitting there just
being like I hope they don't find out
today is the day that I just didn't
learn how to act so I'm just always not
trying to trying not to make mistakes
working across from Jonah because that's
what I was working with most of the
movie
overwhelming because I'm a big big big
big Jonah Hill fan
um but it became cool because we just
started to build a rapport but like
initially I was just like I can't
believe this is happening and I was just
walking in every day like
basically what Travis saying just hoping
I didn't mess up like we would do cuts
and I'd be like did I do enough you're
fine I'm like okay well I want to be a
specific Jonah I've seen Jonah work on
set and he is amazing at improvising and
he is just so in the moment and you have
key scenes where you're talking in front
of Mike uh you know talking podcast and
you are talking about real issues and
I'm curious how much are you diverting
from what Jonah originally wrote and
finding things in the moment what is
that like trying to keep up with him oh
it was tough you know what I mean like
this is my first movie and I'm playing
across from Jonah Hill and he is he's
sharp he's very sharp so like the first
couple of days it was like I would go
home like Sam you gotta you gotta step
it up you know like but I feel like I
got there and we ended up have feeling
like finding a really good rapport with
one another I definitely want to know
for both of you what was it like
watching the film for the first time
because there's so many like cringe
moments I watched and I'm like oh my God
please stop talking you know with
certain characters and what they're
saying and I'm just curious what it was
like for both of you uh I hate watching
myself I don't like watching myself as
soon as I come on the screen no matter
what's going on I burst into a sweat and
I just sit there and melt into a chair
and then uh at the end of the movie I'm
acting like everything was fine and I'm
like I love everything I did in that
yeah no matter what do not like watching
myself at all as soon as I start talking
I'm like shut up
what are you saying so it's like
I don't even know if I have a real
perspective because once I'm looking at
myself my brain is just like melted I
agree with you when I see interviews
with myself I'm like get cut away you
know what I mean move on they're not
they're not here for you you know I'm
I'm curious if I'm not mistaken you you
worked on SNL for a while and I'm
curious when you what what was the
sketch that you got on air that you were
still surprised you were able to get it
on air
I'm all honestly anytime I got a sketch
on I was surprised to be quite honest
because it's just such a tough job and
it's so hard to get anything on but um I
mean I don't really have like a specific
one like the the one we did with Eddie
The Velvet Jones one was just I was like
I don't know if they're gonna let velvet
Jones come back because in nowadays it's
kind of a controversial character so
that was kind of surprising but like
dope like definitely have an individual
question for you uh I am a big fan of
Dave thank you and I'm curious what you
can tease for it certain upcoming season
that may have just finished filming
April 5th it comes out
um I'm not allowed to say the guests
that aren't announced so I'm just
excited for everybody to see it there's
a
this is the most fun season to film
um I had a great time well the thing
about the show is it feels like it's
been getting bigger as it's been going
on I would imagine it was easier to get
guest stars and people to appear this
year yeah for sure for sure 100 I had my
first uh adult white woman fan out
yesterday at a Bottega store that was
insane she was like probably mid 60s and
she like turned to Corner she said oh
and I was like I was like oh no I'm
going to jail and she was like I'm such
a fan of the show I was like oh okay
thank you please say that louder so
nobody else's uh but
um yeah that show's grown so much and
it's done so much for me so I'm so
thankful for it but I enjoyed filming
this season the most a question for both
of you I love learning about the bee
behind the scenes about like making of
shows TV everything for you people what
do you think soon to be fans of the show
will be surprised to learn about like
the making of the movie
a lot of the time we weren't making
anything we were just sitting around all
this seems to be shot I feel like we
shot twice and it was like all right
we're done yeah maybe
um surprised to find out I think people
might be surprised to find out like how
much we were all like hanging I think
sometimes people think yo they should
move and they just all go to their
trailers and like sit there until it's
time but and I've been on sets like that
but this experience was like we would
hang out and talk like and kind of
forget that we were doing it yeah
oh yeah we gotta go shoot because we've
been talking and kicking it so long yeah
I thought Kenya did I really liked also
the editing between scenes the way like
he uh you know you obviously you know
what I'm talking about but I gotta go uh
that note I'm just gonna say congrats on
the movie thank you both nothing but the
best thank you